Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Buonasera a tutti.
Mi viene da sorridere
perché di solito, nel mio lavoro,
sono io che metto
altre persone sul palcoscenico,
metto altre persone
davanti alle telecamere;
e oggi che ci sono qui io,
effettivamente dico
che non è così semplice.
Vi racconto un film,
la storia di un bambino.
Questo sono io quando avevo quattro anni:
sì, avevo i capelli.
(Risate)
Da bambino avevo tre sogni semplici:
diventare un giocatore NBA
di pallacanestro,
diventare un giocatore
di calcio di serie A,
o diventare un attore di Hollywood.
Tre sogni comuni, che hanno
un minimo comune denominatore:
una grande ambizione.
Però anche tre sogni, a pensarci bene,
che bambini della mia età,
cresciuti negli anni '80, avevano.
Cresciuti col Verona di Bagnoli -
io sono di Verona;
cresciuti con le prime
immagini NBA in Italia;
cresciuti con film come "E.T.",
come "La storia infinita",
che hanno segnato una generazione.
E da bambino avevo una grande fantasia,
una grande creatività,
e alla notte sognavo molto.
E con pazienza, ogni mattina
raccontavo a mia mamma cosa vedevo.
Sognavo castelli fantastici,
paesaggi infiniti, animali selvaggi.
Un sera, durante un sogno:
(Video)
"Zeno? Sveglia! Sveglia!
Io sono Danilo Gallinari.
Adesso non mi conosci,
ma sicuramente in futuro
avrai l'opportunità di conoscermi.
Volevo dirti che dobbiamo
riconoscere il fatto
che non sarai mai un giocatore NBA,
non sarai sicuramente mai buono come me:
però avrai una tua speranza in futuro,
e soprattutto il tuo futuro sarà roseo;
e un giorno capirai che ci sono
tante cose che ti aspettano davanti a te".
Gallinari uccideva
le mie ambizioni NBA fin da bambino.
Senza problemi: sarei diventato
un grande giocatore di calcio
e avrei vinto la coppa del mondo
con la maglia della nazionale italiana.
Passa un po' di tempo, altro sogno:
(Video)
"Ciao Zeno, sono Alessandro Del Piero.
Ora non mi conosci,
però sono qui per dirti
una cosa molto importante,
anche duretta da digerire:
non diventerai mai un calciatore,
non diventerai mai
un campione del mondo di calcio.
È impossibile, credimi:
so che è dura,
ma è meglio che te lo dica adesso
così ti concentri su altre cose.
Una cosa bella e positiva
te la devo dire, però:
diventeremo grandi amici,
e magari diventerai un campione del mondo
in un'altra attività.
Per cui, ci vediamo presto.
Ciao!"
I miei due idoli sportivi uccidevano
ogni ambizione sportiva che avevo.
Quindi, con due sogni falliti su tre
ho pensato che il terzo
fosse troppo difficile da raggiungere.
E ho virato su qualcosa di più sicuro,
qualcosa che avevo:
avrei seguito le orme della mia famiglia,
e avrei lavorato
nella società di costruzioni
con mio papà, che ho sempre ammirato.
Era una strada sicura.
E per questo mi sono laureato
in architettura a Firenze.
Più che della parte progettuale, però,
mi ha sempre interessato
la parte commerciale del lavoro.
E finito con gli studi in Italia
sono andato in America, a Los Angeles,
per imparare come gli americani
spiegavano il marketing,
come insegnavano le tecniche di vendita,
tutte cose che mi sarebbero servite,
di lì a poco, nel mio lavoro.
E nel frattempo, finché ero a Los Angeles
mi innamoravo di questa splendida città,
e Hollywood iniziava ad essere vicina,
anche dal punto di vista geografico.
Ma la mia vita era su binari ben precisi:
lavorare con la mia famiglia.
Ma siamo all'interno
di un film, ve l'ho detto.
E come in ogni film c'è un colpo di scena,
un twist dellla sceneggiatura,
come dicono gli americani:
la crisi economica che avanza in Italia
toglie ogni ambizione,
la strada sicura che c'era prima
non c'è più, le sicurezze spariscono.
E allora mi viene in mente una frase,
che mi diceva sempre mio padre:
(Video)
"Zeno, ricordati il mio consiglio:
cerca una nicchia di mercato
e prova ad essere il migliore".
Nel momento di massima difficoltà
mi sono detto: cosa faccio?
Mi arrendo o combatto?
Dovevo ripartire da zero:
anzi, facendo un gioco di parole
con il mio nome, ripartire da Zeno.
Fai quello che sei, mi sono detto.
In tasca avevo passione e ambizione,
e soprattutto una grande idea,
un grande progetto:
puntare a Hollywood.
E con una sorta di "all in"
mi sono buttato dentro in questo mondo,
dove avevo già iniziato a muovermi.
Oggi, dopo 15 anni,
sono proprietario e fondatore
di una società con sede a Beverly Hills,
che si chiama Cangrande,
il cui nome ovviamente
è un omaggio alla mia Verona.
Il mio lavoro consiste
nel condurre in prima persona
tutte le trattative
per definire la presenza dei grandi nomi
dello sport, della moda,
del cinema, dello spettacolo
ad eventi televisivi,
campagne pubblicitarie,
produzioni cinematografiche.
Ero andato in America per imparare
a gestire e a vendere edifici;
e ad oggi sono un venditore
a tutti gli effetti:
vendo talento, vendo sogni, vendo persone.
Detta così, suona malissimo,
infatti vedo le facce -
(Risate)
Ma siamo all'interno di un film,
non dimenticatelo:
siete voi che dovete distinguere
tra finzione e realtà.
Adesso, usciamo dal set:
vi porto dietro le quinte del mio lavoro
per farvi vedere e spiegarvi
come funziona una trattativa a Hollywood.
Che è un mondo particolare,
un mondo a sé stante,
con regole tutte sue.
In una trattativa,
la fase principale
sono i primi tre minuti,
dove non bisogna mai parlare
dell'oggetto di vendita.
Questa è una cosa
che mi hanno insegnato gli americani,
che ti insegnano a ribaltare i concetti,
vedere le cose da un altro lato.
Un'altra cosa fondamentale:
la stretta di mano conta tantissimo,
è il vostro biglietto da visita.
Quindi, sguardo fisso negli occhi,
sorridete e ripetete
il nome della persona che avete davanti:
è essenziale.
Adesso, restando sempre
in ambito cinematografico,
quanti di voi, su le mani,
si ricordano il film "Jerry McGuire"?
Abbastanza, ok.
C'è una scena bellissima
dove Cuba Gooding Jr. ,
che interpreta un giocatore
di football americano,
fa urlare a Tom Cruise:
"Coprimi di soldi, coprimi di soldi!!",
non so se ve la ricordate.
Questa è una cosa
che possiamo tenere come base
per tutte le cose a Hollywood,
perché se è vero che a Hollywood
tutto si muove con i soldi,
è anche vero che ne hanno abbastanza
per dire no a qualsiasi cosa
gli venga offerto,
se c'è qualcosa
che non quadra nel contorno.
Quindi è altro, spesso,
quello su cui io devo far leva:
devo guardare con i loro occhi,
con una ricerca costante
negli interessi personali,
perché alle volte
il dettaglio fa la differenza.
Quello che viene proposto in contorno
è più importante
di quello che c'è sul piatto.
Perché a Hollywood -
io ho una regola
che mi tengo sempre in mente.
La chiamo "5x1".
La divido in due fasi: ricerca e chiusura.
Mi do cinque tentativi
per trovare il talent giusto,
e un mese di tempo
per chiudere trattativa e contratto.
Se esco da questi paletti,
so che la situazione
non è cosi tranquilla,
perché vuol dire che una delle due parti
non ha urgenza di chiudere.
Quindi devo essere bravo
a spingere sui tasti giusti.
Perché a Hollywood
è come una partita a poker,
dove devi essere un chirurgo:
hai zero margine di errore.
Non puoi sbagliare,
perché altrimenti sei fuori.
Devi essere bravo ad anticipare
le mosse di chi ti sta di fronte.
È come un duello di spada:
devi sapere quando affondare il colpo
e quando tirarti indietro.
Perché una fase essenziale
di una trattativa
è tenere sempre il coltello
dalla parte del manico,
è qui è molto difficile,
perché sei tu che insegui loro
e sei tu che speri che loro ti ascoltino.
Il tutto deve essere sempre fatto
con la massima specializzazione
e precisione.
Perché è un lavoro
dove la concentrazione deve essere massima
e la professionalità altissima.
Perché se non conosci
le regole di questo gioco,
non arrivi al traguardo.
È un lavoro che puoi fare da solo.
24 ore al giorno disponibile,
perché hai clienti in tutto il mondo
e devi onorare i loro fusi orari;
da solo perché la tua forza
sta nel rapporto di fiducia che hai:
con i clienti da una parte;
e con gli attori e gli agenti
dall'altra parte,
che vogliono che sia tu che muovi i fili,
vogliono sentire la tua voce.
Ne consegue che l'unica,
e la più forte forma di vendita, qui,
è il passaparola,
la tua reputazione
è quella che ti precede.
Adesso vi ho dato cinque punti
che possiamo prendere e, teoricamente,
trasferire a ogni trattativa.
E invece no,
perché alla fine l'unica cosa
che conta veramente è l'esperienza.
Quando si lavora
con la soggettività degli altri,
e qui gli altri sono volubili,
non c'è una regola fissa,
non c'è uno schema predefinito.
Un attore, un artista,
ha un talento enorme
e una sensibilità molto particolare,
che si esprime sotto varie forme.
E le richieste che ti fanno, alle volte,
sono molto particolari.
Gli americani dicono
"The devil is in the details":
il diavolo sta nei dettagli.
Adesso vi faccio alcuni esempi di dettagli
risultati fondamentali
per chiudere dei contratti.
Questo cane è stato fondamentale
per chiudere un contratto
da due milioni di dollari.
Il cane!
Questo è un cane famoso
perché il suo padrone è molto famoso,
e dovunque va il padrone, va il cane.
E il trattamento che deve essere
riservato a questo cane
è un trattamento
cinque stelle extra lusso,
perché loro te lo richiedono.
Ti chiedono 20 giochi per il cane,
ti chiedono un letto comodo per cani:
ma non uno, tre.
Perché uno deve essere messo in albergo,
uno deve essere messo nel camerino,
uno deve essere messo nel set.
E ti chiedono un cibo
degno di un tre stelle Michelin.
Questo è un cocktail
che si chiama "Pennicilin",
quanti di voi tigri del sabato sera
lo conoscono, vediamo?
Nessuno?
No, uno.
Un eroe.
Questo è il cocktail preferito
da un famoso attore.
Firmo [con] questo attore,
dopo un minuto mi arriva questa mail.
Titolo: Pennicilin cocktail.
Sotto, la ricetta.
Telefono, dico fra me e me
"Faccio un controllo perché sono educato".
Li chiamo e dico:
"Guardate, ho ricevuto questa mail:
Pennicilin cocktail.
Credo che sia per il vostro barista
che sta organizzando la serata."
Risposta: "No, è il cocktail
preferito dall'attore.
Devi dire al tuo cliente
di predisporre un barista,
24 ore su 24 disponibile,
pronto a prepararglielo."
In tre giorni l'ha preso una volta.
(Risate)
C'era lì il barista.
Sei valigie piene di scarpe,
richiesta che mi viene fatta
da un'artista donna.
Vedo uomini che scuotono
la testa, e dicono:
"Sì, anche mia moglie me la fa,
e non è un'artista".
(Risate)
Erano 100 paia di scarpe,
per due giorni di campagna pubblicitaria.
Se l'artista fosse stata sveglia -
perché ho fatto i conti - 24 ore su 24,
avrebbe potuto cambiarsi
un paio di scarpe ogni 33 minuti.
Pensate la faccia del cliente
quando gli sono andato a dire
che doveva pagare
decine di migliaia di euro
per trasportare queste valigie.
Però, senza valigie
non arrivava l'artista.
E questi sono dettagli
di un mondo particolare,
dove la forza è la creatività.
A Los Angeles c'è una luce particolare,
sarà la temperatura che è
tra i 20 e 25 gradi tutto l'anno:
distingui l'estate dall'inverno
a seconda di quando tramonta il sole.
Ma a Hollywood, e a Los Angeles,
hai la sensazione
di voler far qualcosa
e poter fare qualcosa,
e Hollywood è un microcosmo
dove entra il meglio del meglio,
dove il livello intellettuale
delle persone è altissimo.
Dove ti giudicano
per quello che hai in testa,
non per quello che appari.
E dove c'è un continuo sgorgare di idee,
e sei sicuro
che l'idea che sta uscendo
in questo momento
è migliore di quella precedente.
Ma la forza di questo sistema,
che vive su un'estrema competitività,
è al suo tempo anche la sua debolezza.
Perché è una centrifuga
che ti prende e ti travolge.
A Hollywood, ogni giorno è una battaglia.
E nulla è sicuro, neanche per gli attori,
perché tutti i lavori sono instabili.
E se c'è una cosa che capisci subito
è che da fuori sembra un mondo enorme,
in realtà alla fine è un microcosmo
e l'élite è una punta di una piramide
dove tutti si conoscono,
ma se sbagli sei fuori.
Perché alla fine, quello che conta
è quello che tu porti.
Io, oggi, vivo a Beverly Hills,
e con Hollywood ci lavoro ogni giorno.
E se dovessi scrivere una lettera,
se dovessi parlare al bambino Zeno Pisani
gli direi di stare tranquillo,
che alla fine tutto si realizzerà -
anche se, diciamo, in maniera diversa.
Gli direi di stare tranquillo,
di credere in sé stesso,
perché la passione è quello che conta.
L'amore nelle cose che si fanno,
anche se l'amore costa sacrificio.
Ed è vero, per fortuna non sono io
a recitare su un palco,
altrimenti la tensione mi distruggerebbe.
Non ci sono io nei film,
non sono diventato un attore;
non ci sono io
nelle campagne pubblicitarie.
Ma sapere che quell'artista è lì
perché io ho contribuito a fare qualcosa,
e perché c'era un bambino che sognava,
mi rende veramente orgoglioso.
Come dicono gli americani,
"Shoot for the moon: even if you miss,
you'll land among the stars":
Punta sempre alla luna:
anche se la mancherai,
comunque atterri fra le stelle.
A oggi -
(Applausi)
A oggi, sogno ancora molto
la notte, come da bambino:
solo che al posto di raccontare
i sogni a mia mamma,
oggi li racconto a mia moglie.
C'è stata un'evoluzione.
E pochi giorni fa, durante un sogno:
(Video)
Ricky Martin [Italian]:
"Zeno, sono Ricky Martin.
Benvenuto a Hollywood, fratello"
(Applausi)
E questa è la fine del mio film.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)